most of you said that your primary
emotions when it comes to money are fear
shame and guilt and finally 80% of
people in America have said they've been
in this financial situation for most of
our adult life guys this is the moment
to decide are you going to break the
cycle you've been trapped most of your
ad life are you going to break this
we've all got enough excuses not enough
time not enough money it's my parents
fault it's my spouse's fault it's the
president's fault fault it's not at some
point it's my fault now these things may
not be your fault but they are your
responsibility and it comes down to a
choice you have the right and the
obligation to do something different